just got the child when i talked to him
you know just like as a camera person
should come naturally to you we don't
know how good we have it
right here in america
that's true you can be whatever you want
to be right here in america
it can't get much better than that a lot
of a lot of countries
can't do that you know you don't dealt
with
what you have and that's it yeah um
what about germany
i have no idea what about germany
uh germany is like such a great country
yeah i i don't know much
um spreckenzie deutsch
nine
that's about all i know well i think
america is better than germany
america is better in germany home in the
free land of the brave
yep absolutely positively
absolutely rock on
thank you for uh you know being a part
of the american economy i'm hans
i do stand-up comedy and i live in a van
i need a realty
yeah can you realty me up it
all depends on what you want i want to
not be cold
anymore
[Laughter]
i don't even know what to say to that do
your homes come with heating
they do come with it they do come with
heating yeah i'm sold